Donald Trump is taking new steps every
day to turn our country into the world
largest dave and buster's he recently
asked Congress to cut 1.5 billion
dollars from the Department of the
Interior which funds our national parks
not impossible to imagine that the parks
need to privatize to stay open meaning
that we have some desi old faithful
spraying ice-cold PBR all over a sexy
transformer yeah bumblebee shakedown
pony comb wait wait wait greatness Trump
games and all mustache twirling hound
releasing evil I mean he's just pledged
to donate his first presidential salary
payment to the Park Service oh that's a
nice thing to do so to put that in
perspective if you divide the salary
amongst the 417 parks and monuments each
will receive a whopping $187 85 cents
[Applause]
the environment is saved no one has to
close now that they're getting
approximately amount that little Jason
Adler got for his Bar Mitzvah nobody
there's there's Jason could have saved a
park in jerk to the size of our
comedians what are America's wide open
space is going to do with our almost
$200 in new money Kevin Smith they could
pay Russian hookers to pee on them okay
I used to Tyler use condoms for me and
all my Rangers whoopee Rob Riggle they
could probably afford to put that smokey
bear guy in rehab it's about time
someone stepped in he needs some kind of
an intervention the guy will smoke
anything yeah anything only you are